okay well other than the turkey nothing
says Thanksgiving Day quite like
football this is the 88th year of the
NFL's annual tradition which kicks off
with the Bills versus the Lions here on
CBS joining us now to break it all down
is Super Bowl champ Phil Simms two-time
Super Bowl champs hello break it down
for me the former quarterback is now
host of CBS Sports NFL on CBS good
morning Phil first up is Thanksgiving
tradition and we know this the lions are
playing their 83rd annual game this year
up against the bills do they have a shot
to pull off an upset
well yeah first off I'll just say this
you guys it's Thanksgiving day it's in
the morning you're having way too much
fun you got to settle down a little bit
but uh
you know when you see this game the
Lions being at home Thanksgiving Day
they've won three games in a row
emotionally they got to be really up and
you know I think the fans will be even
into it more than usual because the the
lions are showing some daylight here
winning some football games but they are
going Jared Goff there's a good picture
Jared Goff good-looking young guy
quarterback he's playing really well the
offense they put up points they gain
yards all this so it always gives them a
chance and they have struggled to hold
on to to leads in games late and that's
one of the reason why the record is not
as good as it should be
uh Phillips Vlad let's talk uh Giants
and Cowboys both teams are having pretty
good Seasons uh but let's specifically
talk about the New York football Giants
a team that you played for for many
years your childhood Idol of mine are
they for real this year Phil
uh you know listening
I'm not gonna are they for real whatever
first off thank you for the compliment I
didn't know I had any fans out there for
my playing days but stop that's okay but
uh yeah listen the Giants I'm worried
about a couple things today they're
going to play a cowboy team usually
after you have big victories and
everybody patch on the back you have a
little bit of a letdown talking about
the Dallas Cowboys but they emotionally
it's it's so quick for them and they
needed to come back and beat the
Minnesota Vikings because the way they
played the week before I think the
Giants are catching them at a really
tough time and also the Giants offensive
line a little beat up wide receivers
beat up so there's a lot of obstacles to
overcome for the for the New York Giants
today but by the way the couple good
things uh Brian dables did an
unbelievable job with the New York
Giants so far this year and Daniel Jones
and saquon Barkley been carrying the
football team two big question marks for
the football for them coming into the
year and they've answered those they
played very well and let's see if the
Giants can hang on and win a couple
games down the stretch to get themselves
elves in the playoffs and Phil there's a
third big game today folks will be
watching that's the Viking Patriots game
it's been a decade since what the
Patriots played on Thanksgiving and the
Vikings are coming off this loss just
from last weekend so who are you picking
here who has it do uh Bill Belichick's
Patriots really stand a chance
oh sure they stand a chance Mike Jones
played pretty well for him last week
against the Jets of their defense of the
Patriots is getting better and better
they can rush the passer something they
haven't really been good at for years
and you look on the other side the
Minnesota Vikings oh my gosh they got
embarrassed by the Dallas Cowboys so
when you get embarrassed in the National
Football League the following week you
listen to the coaches you really do a
lot of uh checks on yourself or whatever
and you pay attention you're nervous
you're anxious and all those things
really work out in your favor so I think
the Patriots are going into a tough spot
up there with that crowd that team that
was embarrassed by the Cowboys it's
going to be good low scoring I think and
I think the Minnesota Vikings will find
a way to squeeze out a victory
Phil uh no one knew Thanksgiving
football quite like John Madden I know
there's a tribute uh to him he passed
away uh late last year uh what was so
special about him and what what are we
going to miss the most
well one is humor his delivery I mean
you know his delivery was like nothing
we've ever seen on TV as an analyst and
probably not see it again but I think
the big thing his love for the game and
I as an ex player he covered many of the
Giant games that I was fortunate to play
for and when he came around it was
amazing the energy of the football team
everything picked up because John Madden
and Pat Summerall next New York Giant
were there watching practice and
interviewing a lot of guys and stuff
like that but all the Traditions all the
oh bam you know all these words he would
use you know people's noses are running
I'm not going to say how he would say it
and uh just what he brought it and I
think the fans really related to him and
it it came out in his broadcast so
there's a lot of things we miss about
John Madden yeah he was real let's face
it absolutely right absolutely right hey
Phil uh one of our producers at the show
Matt Shelley had a question about the
New York Jets but our senior broadcast
producer in the control room John Towers
telling me we are out of time sorry
Shelly
oh well with you guys and everything
have a great day so but Happy
Thanksgiving tell Sims thank you and you
can tune into the Bills versus Lions
game today at 12 30 p.m Eastern right
here on state Bay f right